[Music]
i got invited to join a men's group with
terry actually yeah i've never done one
of these i don't know if you've done
men's screenings i've never done a men's
grip i have not it's really interesting
i had neither and i was invited to join
one of these men's groups and
essentially
it is
picture eight people over zoom
terry's there as well so you have your
therapist in the room and i'd never done
any type of group therapy thing before
i've done individual therapy and couples
therapy but never group
and
it was he kicks it off by saying okay
we're gonna go around the room and we're
gonna spend everyone gets
10 minutes that to just tell me what's
on your mind what's going on and there's
none of this [ __ ] like well i took
my kids out no that's like no no no what
is it hitting you at a deep level that
you are struggling with and he calls you
on your [ __ ] like if it's such
generic answers because everybody has
their [ __ ] right like the thing that
they're they're struggling with like my
spouse did this or you know
like there could be any slew of
different things that you're running
into you know like right now for me it's
my mom's dealing with cancer right so i
like that was the thing that i went into
and
you spend those first 10 15 minutes
and it's really eye-opening and they put
you in a group of like peers that that
when you look around the room you're
like you're kind of in a similar stage
in life
and
you you have these really deep
conversations and one person can be you
know got caught cheating on their wife
or whatever it may be
and
you realize instantly like oh my god
like so many people actually struggle
with the same things that i struggle
with every single day
in my head which is nice it's refreshing
and then the people that are having the
most pain for that particular session
you do these a couple times a month it's
a two-hour long
session
he'll go deep with those people so say
okay you're the two people today we're
gonna go deep with and then you just
watch as he dissects and just ninjas
around and gets them oftentimes to tears
by the end of it and really really goes
in deep into some of these issues that
these men are bringing up
and
i had never really thought about doing
that and it was really a really
beautiful thing and you're very
supportive like you all you never like j
with they always say does anyone want to
comment on what this person just said
and it's never
about judging them or saying well i
think you're doing this wrong it's more
like this is how this landed on me
is that a rule that was established up
front it is a rule there's a handful of
rules yeah what are the rules
so you you comment on how it landed on
you and how you see it through your lens
but this is only applicable to you
you can say general supportive things
like like i thought you were really
courageous for saying that thank you for
sharing it with me things like that
you can always pass at any time so if
anything makes you uncomfortable you can
always pass
there is 100
like what happens in this room stays in
this room we're talking about some very
kind of crazy topics here that maybe
some people haven't disclosed to their
even closest friends or partners right
there's all kinds of issues that i heard
came up where i was just like i can't
believe we're talking about this but
it's it's nice it's nice to know that
other men are struggling with the stuff
and so
that was fantastic and i've been doing
that for a few months now
and it's led me to just
i don't know there was some great
insights in there
that i just came away with but then it
led me actually to terry's books as well
because you know these are quite
expensive kind of groups as terry's a
pretty sought-after type of individual
therapist
and so he has this book that he turned
us onto called fierce intimacy that's
one of his books
yes
fierce intimacy and it's great he reads
his own audiobook so it's on audible and
it's how to communicate with love and
respect even when you argue
and this has been just a game changer
for me when it comes to
how i can
relate how i can
prevent self-sabotaging habits
you know
just how to deal with your partner
in a way that is constructive and moving
forward
and not judging and being able to know
when to let information in and take it
in and digest it and let it hit your
stuff like internally and when to know
that the other person is just venting
and actually it's coming more from them
and it's okay to put a wall up sometimes
and block that information because it's
where they're coming from and it
shouldn't land and hit you in the wrong
way and it it's it's such a beautiful
simple framework
that i absolutely love and the other
thing i love about him is he was kind of
a pioneer in this space he's not a
therapist that that that that just sits
there and listens to both sides and like
it sounds like what you're saying is
this he takes sides and therapy he's
like he's like no that's [ __ ] wrong
like you're doing this like she's right
here or you know like and so you hear a
lot of that happening in this
conversation and i i'm like finally you
know like yeah yeah i like a therapist
pick up because sometimes i know i know
i'm right sometimes you know
so
so i just found this guy to be really
refreshing and i and and probably people
that are some people are laughing
because they know this is a really
popular person i first i had heard of
him was six months ago but he's a very
famous therapist but anyway highly
recommend fierce intimacy dario and i
both listen to it my wife and i both
listen to it and it's already improved
the way that we communicate with each
other the way we have conversations the
way we let information flow in and
actually land on us
so i put it in there in terms of books
to recommend
how long is that book
i did it on audible so i think it was
like seven hours or something like that
yeah so it's probably like 250 pages
something like that yeah somewhere
around there yeah pretty easy do you
think you have found it helpful because
you are
also in the group or is it do you think
it's effective as a standalone the book
absolutely because daria listened to not
being in the group obviously and she
found it effective as a standalone as
well and i the reason i like it is it it
just doesn't dance around
this like we always have to be head over
heels and love it's like every single
day that you wake up
one person might be up one person might
be down and it's always about finding
your way back to that middle safe like
comfort zone and relationships are
nothing but
you have these moments of beautiful
things and bliss happening but largely
it's about
the other the other points right and
like how you get the flu states yeah and
returning back to that state of health
right and in understanding and how to
how how to both know that you're on the
same team and and have the same goals in
mind and working with a framework that
that supports that so yeah i don't know
i really loved it and and i'm not a i
i've really struggled i've listened to a
couple other relationship books because
you know i'm always trying to improve
i've been married nine years now and and
darren and i are in a really good place
now but you know me tim we've had these
conversations like one-on-one
there's bumps with all these
relationships right
and it's like you know dory and i did
couples therapy for a bit especially
when you introduce kids into the
equation my god that changes everything
and so it's it's like
this is this is the first time i read a
book where i was like this this is
speaking to me and working so i want to
throw it out there that's great that's a
big deal
you know i i have
considered men's groups
a number of times
i think i probably have
on one hand
like an unfair although i've seen this
before
it's so it's not totally unfair like
some men's groups like all right we're
gonna go in the woods and like
you know wear furs and bang on drums and
like yell and scream and i'm like uh
not sure that's
the the medicine i need right now and
then
you know i've had some misgivings at
different points but the
the kind of
meta commentary that i would i would
make and this has been a conversation
and it's a conversation i've had
actually with
quite a few
women
because
i've just observed
that
like women i think are in general again
i'm painting with a broad brush but
better at kind of social cohesion
and
gathering
and that type of
communal intimacy
and
there there are very few places you know
outside of like a sports team or the bar
or
fill in the blank option c
where
men have those
communal experiences but if you look
back at our
just
history right if we look back hundreds
of years thousands of years that was an
inbuilt feature of different communities
and
i think that
that society at large ends up in a very
precarious
uh volatile
situation
when
men especially younger men don't have
that right it's like okay if you have
somebody who is feeling alienated who is
pumped full of hormones like let's just
say like kind of 16 to like
22 right
with no sense of
social belonging
and a lot of
physiologically
driven or at least informed aggression
like that is
a significant societal problem right yes
and
so i've i have thought about that a lot
i mean
go ahead
the other thing too i'll add on top of
that is you know traditionally
when you think about men getting
together and shooting the [ __ ] you know
it's it is that bar setting is that
sports game or whatever it may be and
it's very high level right like at that
point you're just like i have things
like ah you know wife's doing this blah
blah
like you don't have the permission
really like in my group i was like
my mom had her cancer return
like
i'm going to miss her when she's gone
because i'm her little boy and like i
will miss the feeling of my head on her
shoulder and like stuff that i'm just
like so deep and intimate to me because
i love her so deeply yeah and it's like
you don't get that over a beer
necessarily to be able to go and just
see other men around the table doing the
same thing because we all at that point
have set the ground rules it's a safe
space and we can we can just really
really let it out and lots of tears come
and one of the things terry always says
that's really interesting
during it
people will start to cry men will start
to cry and tears will slip and he goes
what are those tears saying
what are those what are those tears
saying right now and it's like it's like
give me more give me a more open that
door a little bit further than you're
comfortable opening up like you yeah i
triggered something here come the tears
unpack that further and then it just
goes from there and it's deeper and
deeper layers and it's released man i
mean you know how this is psychedelics
help with this a lot you know the number
when i did my high dose mushroom
experience i was sobbing after you know
because my father passed away it was
like it gave me that permission to let
that stuff go
and it's it's a very special thing when
when you can do it because it's so
healthy
you